from one Hall of Fame quarterback to
another drew brees remember yesterday we
talked about whether or not he made a
Freudian slip or Chris's you would say
Freudian slip on whether or not when
Sean Payton was talking about Brees
whether or not this was Brees final
season yesterday meeting with reporters
Sean Payton had to walk back his comment
that this is Drew Brees final season
here's Sean Payton from Wednesday yeah
look I love Sean Payton I love drew
Brees but this is Drew Brees last year
with the Saints if Drew Brees wants to
play in 2021 Chris he's going to be
playing for somebody else they're not
going to pay Drew Brees 25 million and
then sign Taysom Hill to a contract when
he's an unrestricted free agent they may
have to franchise tag
Taysom Hill next year they're not gonna
have 45 50 million dollars tied up in
the quarterback position next year
Taysom Hill gets the gig next year drew
Brees loses the gig next year and
whether it was a Freudian slip or
wishful thinking Sean Payton knows in
his heart that this is it for Drew Brees
because next year the page turns to
Taysom Hill I would think so Mike that
would be the the general thought I think
for anybody that's following the league
it certainly seems to be going that way
I mean we know the Taysom Hill has great
potential and then he's loved by Sean
Payton and Sean Payton is you know one
of the greatest offensive minds and
quarterback guys we've seen in in
history of the NFL so he's certainly is
spotted a talent there too and yeah Mike
I'm with you
like I maybe it was a slip of the tongue
I wouldn't be shocked $2 if it was just
like an intentional thing and now you
just come back uh I'm a dummy I messed
up I mean Sean Payton's great that way
but I wouldn't be shocked if that was an
intentional hey I'm just gonna throw
this out there right now to get people
to start wrapping their head around this
idea that this is drew Brees is last
year but the New Orleans Saints kind of
speaking it into existence even if right
so inadvertently and I agree right if
you look it's Hill and look Payton found
Taysom Hill he's developed a sim Hill
and I think he wants to construct an
offense just like the Ravens did for
Lamar Jackson
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports